hello everyone my name is Sally I am an
engineer on Google kubernetes engine and
I'm joined here by Aparna saying how she
is the group program manager a product
manager for all of kubernetes and google
kubernetes engine pleasure to have you
with us a Poorna thank you son
pleasure to be here so you have been
deeply involved with a strategy for gke
and defining the product vision what do
you think sets the the offering that GK
he has today in terms of what customers
are asking for yeah sure yeah I've been
with the project for the last three and
a half years so really sort of seen it
grow from a baby until you know I would
say much broader enterprise adoption
both in the open source as well as of
course on our cloud with gke and really
have been with the gke service from the
beginnings as well as we worked through
first introducing it as a service and
building all of these enterprise-grade
features into it for enterprise
readiness making sure upgrades are you
know much more automated and you know
low impact for the customers and moving
into the future providing GK on Prem so
what I've heard from customers and end
users you know both OpenSocial users and
customers is that you know they want to
be able to use gke in their own on-prem
environment which is why we're
introducing GK on Prem and why we
introduced it at UCP next and you know
we're moving forward with that
and they want to have kind of Google's
expertise from having managed it in
production as a service for the last
three and a half years as well as the
expertise that comes from being directly
involved deeply with the open source
project so you probably saw in my
keynote you know I showed the
distribution of contributions to
kubernetes open source over the last
year based on CNC the statistics you
know Google is contributing 40-plus
percent of that and so what that means
is that we're very current with all of
the issues with kubernetes we're
building solutions and so when you
partner with Google you have that
partnership with you know the core
maintainer and so for example on gke
we're always
ahead in you know knowing what's coming
up you know for our users both in the
open source and on and on the cloud with
vulnerabilities security vulnerabilities
that are happening you know we're always
patching them ahead of time and then
bringing them into gke making sure that
the most secure version is there same
thing with the with the versions and
upgrades you know finding the problems
and making sure that the customers
doesn't just don't have to worry about
it so that's kind of the second piece
customers love kubernetes I would say
you know for all of the future
functionality the resiliency the
productivity the higher utilization that
you get when you run your applications
on kubernetes but they also don't always
want to manage kubernetes and have to
keep up with all of the capabilities and
program all of the capabilities so we
try and provide a much more managed
distribution you know we'll be providing
it on Prem we've been providing it in
the cloud for several years not only
managing your masters obviously managing
the sizing and the backup of your sed
and you know scaling of the masters but
also managing much more of your cluster
itself with with node upgrades and note
auto repair and node auto scaling these
are some of the features that over time
we brought in to make sure that
customers can worry less about the
infrastructure and then I think I talked
about it in my keynote today we're
building and also up the stack you know
providing now no doubt of provisioning
so you can kind of you know be
hands-free you don't have to worry as
much about is the cluster running you
can focus on what do you want to run in
the cluster and so we've actually just
this week in fact earlier today
announced that is do on GK is moving to
beta and it's available for existing
clusters as well as new clusters and you
know we're going to be providing it with
a single click install which I demoed in
the keynote and also you know providing
basic lifecycle operations so upgrading
is Gio so it's really kind of a lot
easier to use this to you you don't have
to know a lot of the guts of it yourself
but you can get the benefit of being
able to monitor and view and discover
all of your services in the entire
across your clusters and then also be
able to set security policies ensure you
know encrypted traffic and
authentication and then also be able to
use the basic functionalities of a proxy
like you know for load balancing
obviously and also for traffic control
so those are the capabilities you sort
of get for not entirely for free but
much more easily in gke and then lastly
is bringing that develop developer
experience with key native and the GK
serverless add-on which is still in
alpha but that is also something
customers have been looking for they
want they love kubernetes but then they
want to give their developers kind of a
hands-free experience where they can
just go use all of the functionality
write their code focus on their code and
not have to worry about all the rest not
have to worry about setting up ingress
not have to worry about you know
exposing their services and how to
expose their services not have to worry
about how to auto scale and those are
the things that Canada does really well
under the covers so I would say you know
those are the three things that
customers been asking for give me
something in my own environment give me
something that I don't have to manage a
lot of and give me a good developer
experience for my developers so is it
fair to summarize it as with --gk eve
we've kind of built this massive open
source ecosystem with kubernetes ISTE o
Kay native and we've now made it very
very dead simple to use on the cloud
side and we're bringing that simplicity
over to people's data centers and kind
of completing the story and is that what
customers are asking for yeah well so I
think the ecosystem is actually one of
the best parts of working on this
project and one of the best parts of
working with an open-source community
and the way that the project is
architected it's very much o amenable to
extensions and you know that you've been
working on CSI which just moved to GA in
1.13 so congratulations we got a lot of
such interfaces and what that does is it
it really opens the project up to an
ecosystem a very rich ecosystem that can
build and not just build but also
customize kubernetes for specific
environments you know customize it for
the on-prem environment that has a
particular type of storage or particular
type of networking preference or a
particular type of security preference
so all of those things are pluggable and
from a business perspective what it
means is that we can we can
we can bring that ecosystem into our
cloud so kubernetes you know I try to
think of it I like to think of it and
call it a kübra kubernetes first cloud
Google is a kubernetes first cloud it is
because you know gke is one of the most
popular services on our cloud you know
the vast majority of our customers use
UK in some form or another you know
everyone from you know New York Times
PayPal eBay these are some of the you
know and every major retailer you know
that's kind of fresh in our minds
because we just went through Black
Friday Cyber Monday and we scaled all
these retailers to new heights in terms
of their business all with zero outages
so very very proud of that really kind
of coming to maturity so Google is
really a kubernetes first cloud you know
brings we think about well how can
kubernetes run well what kind of
networking features can we build like
Network endpoint groups is an example I
pee aliases is an example what can we do
to make the experience better for
kubernetes users on Google cloud and
when you have the the kubernetes first
cloud I think it makes sense as an
ecosystem provider to really come in and
provide your offering on Google cloud
and so that's what we've done with the
kubernetes marketplace but then the rich
thing here the really rich aspect is
that we're providing that gk experience
now in your own data center on Prem so
that same ecosystem that's in the
kubernetes marketplace now carries over
and now has much broader reach even
beyond Google Cloud 2 on Prem that
sounds awesome
let's switch gears a little bit and talk
about coupon you have been to a quite a
few coupons how does this feel different
from others has a real special place in
my heart and this is my fifth or sixth
cube Khan and I and I you know I've been
comparing and contrasting Seattle is of
course a very special location we have a
big presence in Seattle a lot of a lot
of my team a lot of the kubernetes team
is based here and I've been here I think
this is the second or third time that
we've been in Seattle and this is the
obviously the largest cube con that
we've had with eight or 8,000 or 9,000
attendees right and this is the
time we've been in this huge venue I
think it's been very well done you know
it seems very approachable or a lot of
people a lot of familiar faces the whole
community is here so it's really great
to meet everyone yeah it's it's a it's a
real tradition and I think in particular
the Google team is out here in full
force I think we got more than 300
people absolutely what are you looking
most forward to this week in terms of
activities going on a coupon well I'm
really looking forward to the keynotes
by Brian grants and same Hawken and
Clayton the stories of the whole days
yeah yeah I don't know what what the
content will be but that is something
that I'm really looking forward to and
then the the cig meetups tend to be you
know the cig a meetings tend to be very
popular as well there's a diversity
luncheon I believe if it hasn't already
passed so I'm looking forward to that
and then just to catching up with all of
the familiar faces in the community and
meeting folks from other companies
especially the you know all of these
companies on security and networking
that the whole ecosystem that has sprung
up I always really enjoy meeting them
and hearing from them and then of course
there are a lot of users a lot of users
and customers here so that's always the
best part and to wrap it up kind of put
you on the spot what's your favorite
coupon memory oh well you know I don't
know if it's my yeah I guess it was kind
of my favorite so two years ago in 2016
when we came to Seattle that was on
November 7th I think ours November 6th
and it was election day and the cube con
after-party right on November 6 we were
all in this like wonderful venue you
know all kinds of candles and beautiful
lights and great snacks and everybody
was watching the election and everybody
was was expecting it to go a certain way
and it went a different way and then the
sort of the morning after you know just
being with it's kind of like being with
your family a little bit but it's a much
more extended family and I felt like it
was kind of nice being with with the
cloud native community yeah I was
talking about Tim earlier today and he
says you know even though this is scaled
to the scale of 8,000 people it still
feels like a big family and I think
that's the beauty of q Khan
thank you very very much for your time
and paranoia and uh we're going to hand
it off
[Music]